I am
happy I know myself I am not personally
responsible for
anything I just apologize about what I
look like uh I didn't have any time to
change I had to like run here straight
from my dad's worst nightmare show is
still going to be filled with 21st
century cynicism the
self-objectification encouraged by
social media the late capitalist
co-option of the queer aesthetic I'm
kidding can you
imagine this is my story I'm not into
conspiracy theories not because I don't
think they're true get them no I'm
kidding people are so critical of young
people at the moment young people are
also desperate to play the victim and I
take that extremely personally I came
here to raise awareness I haven't
decided of what sex is really where I
come into my own as an actor wow I'm
actually just very interested in the
layered Poetics symbolism of anal that's
a per my
right I do this as representation you
know I'm one of the first ever Jewish
people to try stand up
comedy this is the first song I like
ever wrote so it might be a bit
pretentious or adolescent but it's just
a song about my lived experiences being
a 20-some and growing up in this
increasingly scary
time
tonight I'm on tonight and I like to
start with some singing no we don't have
[Music]
time